so hi everyone I'm Ashwin softer
engineer working in Seattle this is not
gonna be a super technical talk so I
hope all if you can follow all the way
through because I'm get my experience in
data science is not vast so hopefully
it'll be accessible to ignore so for a
brief outline I just start off talking a
bit about myself and how I got involved
with MOOCs and talk about how they've
evolved over the years and talk a little
bit about the different styles of MOOCs
and give some tips on how to pick a monk
effectively and how you can use MOOCs to
learn more effectively and end it with
the state of MOOCs today so around six
years ago I was studying computer
science in a small Indian town most of
you probably haven't heard of its called
Palani and Palani was unique in that it
was remote like really remote so this is
where my university was and that's where
the nearest airports were over 125 miles
away so just to get to Palani you had to
fly and then travel like four hours by
Road but to truly understand how remote
Palani was you need to look at the next
image
this is Palani with New York scaled a
hundred times next to it would anyone
like to guess what the pins represent
those are actually McDonald's outlets so
now with now you can truly understand
how far away from civilization I was now
this remoteness may seem like a
disadvantage but to me it meant a
singular advantage I had a lot of free
time and I had to come up with
innovative ways to pass the time or else
I would be poured out of my mind
in addition to that class Palani were
optional at least if you ask the
students they were this was uncommon in
Indian colleges and it meant that for
the first time I could choose what I
wanted to study
and it was in this environment in late
2011 that I came across the first mooks
ML Class DB class and AI class since
this is PI data I'm not gonna be talking
a lot about DB class and you mean you
guys may be wondering what about all the
other online offerings that there were
before these before 2011 stuff like MIT
OpenCourseWare or OCW for short that was
massive it was on the internet after all
it was open accessible to anyone and it
was definitely an online course so why
is this different for me there were two
reasons that this marked the start of
something new one was the intended
audience in the case of MIT or CW which
was recorded in an MIT classroom the
primary audience seemed to be the
students in that class the videos were
structure like reference material and
you didn't really feel engaged you
couldn't talk to the professor or your
fellow classmates the videos also were
very long 15 I think MIT is intro to
algorithms course averages around 15
minutes per video for a total of around
80 hours for the whole course and that
just doesn't fit well for a student on
his computer at home and since yeah
whereas with ml class in your class
there was a significant difference the
intended audience was you the student at
home whether in India or the United
States or anywhere else in the world you
were the ones that the course was made
for and your fellow classmates came from
across different time zones different
cultural backgrounds financial
backgrounds and educational backgrounds
and the online forums served as your
classroom where you could engage not
just with each other but hopefully also
with the teacher side the second the
second reason this represented a
watershed moment for me was the way
these classes were named you know all
letter letter - class and we all know
how important naming is in computer
science right so it this made me feel
like these classes were organized with
the same sense of purpose
and would be organized with the same
style although that was not necessarily
true so going back to Palani I was faced
with a difficult choice I did decide
between either ml flask or AI class and
I did what any sane human being would do
I chose the cute humanoid robot instead
of that creepy cyborg I mean what is
that thing in you ad I'm not sure and
that don't have to be a good forerunner
of orders to come because ml class used
the latest technology available at that
time with digital images and slides
annotated with different colors to
explain different concepts AI class on
the other hand used technology of
yesteryear with low poor lighting low
resolution videos that were out of focus
and if that wasn't good enough you had
the professor's hand obstructing the
video half the time over the next year
ml class transformed into Coursera and
AI class became Udacity in fact if you
try to go to M in Flast or over grea
class or come right now you'd be
redirected to those sites instead and it
looks like at least a few of the people
at MIT seem to agree with me when I said
OCW was not really a mooc because later
that year they offered their own edx
with so many different providers you
guys may be wondering how do i pick a
mooc so the first tip i can give you is
know your flavor luckily all these
different providers have their own
styles which and knowing what style you
like and what style makes it easy for
you to learn may make it easier for you
to pick move with the right provider for
instance Coursera follows a very
traditional style and when I say
traditional I mean it's almost like a
college course that just went online
this is a slide from Geoffrey Hinton
scores neural networks and machine
learning and you can see I don't say
this slide wouldn't be a mess in a
college setting course our videos are
also quite long around 20 minutes or
longer and there may be a question at
the end just to make sure you're paying
attention and this course offers courses
from a variety of different universities
but there's no
and ization across the board the only
standardization seems to be because of
the limitation of their evaluation
framework where all exams are usually
multiple choice questions you'd asked me
on the other hand seems to have learned
and significantly improved from AI class
the hand is still there trying to poke
at the word poker but this time around
the text is visible the videos are shot
around two to three minutes long and
after almost every video there is a
short quiz as you can see on the left I
think that's great for students like me
who snore straight through a 40-minute
lecture the evaluations are also quite
rigorous as opposed to Coursera and
there are a lot of programming
assignments after every week and the
final exam is basically the same but up
by one level with EDX you get a hybrid
approach where they have short videos
but there are slides there's a
transcript running on the side and they
have a mix of both multiple choice
questions and programming questions my
next step would be to use class central
comm and they have reviews for many
different courses and I tend to agree
with many of those reviews although a
fair word of caution they seem to rate
easier courses better and as a result
you will find a lot of intro to CS and
other courses at the top of the rankings
you can think of class central as Yelp
for online courses except all the
courses are free and the open up filter
does nothing because the courses are
massively open as expecting some groans
there but not mine
the third tip would be to know how much
time you can and want to commit in my
experience Coursera courses require
lesser of time time commitment because
and they aren't as rigorous as you rusty
and EDX but your mileage may vary at
this point maybe some of you are
thinking do I even need a MOOC and like
why not just read a book right and if
you guys were thinking that then you're
in very good company because Elon Musk
has a video out there where he talks
about how much he hates videos as a way
for learning things
just because they are so slow whereas he
can like devour books in men and
probably ours that's a good point but I
have a small counter fine how many of
you have seen the Lord of the Rings
movies and how many of you have read the
books so I think there's something about
videos that make them a little less
mentally taxing so I prefer videos to
books and we can probably leverage
videos for better learning so starting
off with some tips for MOOCs first of
all don't beat yourself up if you can't
complete a course or if you fail to
complete a bunch of courses it doesn't
matter for every course I've completed
there like at least two or three that
just have been tossed by the wayside the
whole point of MOOCs is the freedom that
gives you two to leave a course midway
through that you can't find elsewhere so
just don't beat yourself up if you don't
complete process secondly consume videos
quickly a lot of these courses have a
lot of fluff especially in the intro
sections and there are many concepts
discussed at a very basic level just
because of the wide audience that they
are addressing are you frequently watch
videos at 2x or higher and skip forward
there are extensions you can get for
Chrome and Firefox that let you do these
for any html5 videos conversely I would
also like advise you guys to slow down
and absorb the parts where you find that
the concepts aren't coming to you as
clearly the next step is again related
to videos frequently in like in class
lectures just when the professor is
about to embark on a journey to conquer
this vast ocean of knowledge
I find myself drifting off thinking
about random things like why is this
angle called finless porpoise it clearly
has two friends and the answer if
anyone's wondering is because it doesn't
have a toss with another backwood yes
and so by the time I've tuned back in
say by the time if tuned back in the
professor's somewhere else and the
waters are too rough to reach where he
is
and I'm lost without hope and that's the
end of the course for me as I know it
but luckily with online courses I can
rewind zone out a couple of times more
rewind again and then finally get to
where the professor is I think another
useful skill which is also very
difficult to master is effective
note-taking I would take notes really
judicially judiciously especially in the
beginning few chapters of the course and
the intros and stuff it's very easy to
be like really motivated and jot down
everything other professor is saying but
most of the things that are said in the
intro or lessons you won't be finding
useful by the end of the course in
addition this is a graph from duolingo
research which shows how the probability
of remembering decays slower with every
active recall session that you have so I
have come up with a small technique to
leverage this in my note-taking what I
do is I leave I leave out some words
while taking notes maybe just
conjunctions or things like the and and
what this does is it forces me when I
revisit my notes before the next lecture
to read the whole sentence to just fill
in those words
here's that in practice this is on
Evernote this is for a course on
dinosaurs what I've done here is I have
basically written the words but I've
written it in a white text so you have
to highlight them to you and this
provides me an additional advantage in
that each time I come across these notes
I can force my brain to actively recall
what the sentence is talking about so
here it is highlighted the contrast
Evernote has changed that contrast since
I wrote these notes so it's not as
visible and this is these are some of my
notes for ED X's intro to a conference
class which I have published there on
that URL here I've whited out the entire
answer and again when you highlight it
you can see what the actual answer is
another very useful tip I think is that
you guys should use the forums the
forums are the main way you get to
engage with your classmates and with the
professors
and asking questions to clarify concepts
you don't understand or answering
questions that others have to solidify
the concepts that you do understand is
very useful some of the best courses
I've taken have very active engagement
from both the teachers and the students
this is these are posts forum posts from
a course called design of computer
programs on Udacity it's really good if
you want to go from a beginner level in
Python to an intermediate level this was
taught by Peter Norvig and these are all
the posts that he's posted on just one
day on June 4th so this is while he's
holding down of I shouldn't say probably
holding down but why he's I mean keeping
a full-time job at Google as director of
research so he's probably a busy man and
he still finds a lot of time to make
posts and engage with students in fact
he finds so much time that a student
actually asked on the forums how does
professor Nora find time for teaching
and guess who answered that of course
Peter Norvig himself this is another
course that I took where being taught by
a professor from Brown Michael Wittmann
and here on the right you can see this
is the third of the fifth post that we
had in our back and forth where he was
just helping clarify concept and helping
me understand better and I think this is
what made MOOCs really massive and open
for me in the to a sense of the word
because I was in India and he was in the
US and he was it was basically like I
was being taught one-on-one by him I
find that looking for courses that are
run in batches or ones that have just
started tend to have more active forums
than the others for a more modern course
this is these are the stats for forum
posts by Jeremy Howard and Rachel Thomas
who conduct the fast a I course
Rachel stats seems pretty seem pretty
crazy when you see three thousand five
it was read and 170 post created and
then you look at Jeremy's where he's
written over 2,600 posts and read over
15,000 300
so that's a really good indicator of
whether of course is worth taking at
least until this metric is gamed
another useful tip to get the most out
of course is to focus on the assignments
that's your primary way of learning as
this Chinese ancient Chinese proverb
says you can watch the videos as many
times as you like but only when I do
something do I really understand it some
some of the courses that I want to
highlight that had great assignments
were this and again the Berkeley course
the intro to artificial intelligence so
through the course they had you
implement different algorithms for
pac-man starting with a greedy algorithm
ending with a reinforcement learning
algorithm and I created Li week or week
the algorithm got better and by finals
week the algorithm was much better than
you ever could be at this game which is
uplifting and depressing at the same
time and these are some of the jeremy's
course the faster a course has a
assignments where you submit two Kaggle
competitions so that's a great way of
getting real-world experience this is a
post from just two days ago where he is
basically bragging about how good his
course is saying that all the top 5 on
an active competition on cattle are his
students the second ones the second ones
jeremy himself so i think it's very
important not to skip any of the
programming assignments the theoretical
questions can be skipped if necessary
and they but they provide useful if you
just want to make sure you've understood
the concept just being presented the
next step would be to audit effectively
this probably ties up with point zero as
well if a course is just not meeting
your needs or doesn't seem right for you
just don't do it there's so many course
and tutorials out there that you're
better off trying something new than
wasting your time with this particular
course personally I find courses where
teachers visually explain concepts are
more useful than ones where they just
rehash
a textbook in two slides and lastly man
is your time I've already mentioned a
couple of tips like consuming videos
quickly and not doing courses that just
don't work for you I would also like to
talk about a concept mentioned by Cal
Newport associate professor at
Georgetown when he talks about deep work
and the idea behind deep work is that it
takes hours of focused effort to truly
gain insights into something to gain
that those difficult insights which you
just cannot get from working for like a
few minutes and then switching contexts
back and forth with that in mind I like
to take courses that are self-paced
which basically have all their materials
released versus ones that have weekly
deadlines primarily because work and
vacation gets in the way of weekly
deadlines like all the time for a an AML
and MOOCs today this is so today
Coursera Udacity have moved towards a
paid model they still offer courses for
free but it can be really difficult to
find the material both of them only
provide feedback for projects if you pay
and both including EDX only provide
certificates if you pay nowadays this is
a pretty difference from pretty big
difference from when they started when
everything was free this is the website
of deep learning REI if you look at it
you may not know that you can actually
access the materials for free and all
the word wording is like carefully
worded to say try for free or free trial
or financially it is available for
learners who can't afford the fee but if
you actually click on enroll at the very
bottom there's an audit the course
button which you can click to get access
to some of the course materials and with
increasing college costs this move may
not be a big surprise with hacker
bootcamp sprouting up left and right
it looks like education is ripe for
disruption or maybe just right for
making a few quid
however I think this paints a stark
contrast to the original vision that
these founders had here is Sebastien
throngs comment on who's the founder of
audacity his comments on his reddit AMA
where he says I stand behind my promise
that our classes are free emphasis mine
and ice I feel while he's still true to
the letter of his promise with starting
with 2014 when they faced out free
certificates they have slowly been
moving away from the spirit of that
promise
so since 2011 which was when the first
MOOCs were launched there have been a
lot of changes in ml when Andrew ings
machine learning course was launched the
machine learning landscape was wide and
filled with a lot of different
techniques like linear regression
logistic regression SVM's neural nets
PCA and lot of others since then random
not random forests and neural networks
have gained significantly starting with
Alex net winning the imagenet
competition in 2012 followed by vgg and
other neural network based architectures
basically becoming the de facto way to
do image recognition nowadays this was
this change was accelerated by libraries
like tensorflow deep deep learning for
JMX net pi torch and others and their
libraries like Kara's that provide a
simpler API so even beginners or people
who are new to the field can get started
with deep learning the success of sites
like Google comm provide a way to test
your mettle against other practitioners
in your field and that looks like it
ensures that neural networks are random
forests are here to stay most
competitions on Kaggle I think I
actually use are won by techniques that
use random forests so what about new
courses in ml so in today's world in
2017 there are two courses that tackle
the problem of neural nets
and they both tackle a problem very
differently one the first one is deep
learning da di which is run by a drawing
who taught the machine learning course
in collaboration with Coursera in this
course he starts small going over what
makes up in your network and slowly
builds up or a sequence of five courses
to how cnn's work and sequence models
work the other course is course dot
faster di taught by Jeremy Howard and
Rachel Thomas this takes the opposite
approach it goes top-down and is unique
in being one of the few courses that do
in in the very first week you submit and
as you submit an entry to a cattle
competition and view the results by
using vgg
and I think I've heard from a lot of
people that if you complete this course
you're probably on par with many ml
scientists or people who transitioned
into a mad scientist rows today over the
lessons he goes deeper and breaks down
different parts of the CNN architecture
and explains the concepts at a lower
level also after a few years after the
first ml courses were launched like in
2011 I think in 2014
Jupiter notebooks were invented and
faster AI makes great use of them
they're basically great for reproducible
research and reproducible code and
that's that's my talk
[Applause]
so the questioners did you find any real
value in the certifications in terms of
the job market so not really I usually
take this courses just to understand the
concepts and improve my learning I may
have put some of these on my resume I'm
not sure I would like to think they
didn't help too much
yeah I guess I contradicted myself a bit
there good catch
I would say I would prefer courses that
are actually time bucketed if I don't
know the concept well and they finally
because then I can engage with my
students and with the teacher and
clarify all the things that I need to
know but if I do know it at an
intermediate or higher level and I just
want to get a deeper insight then I
would take the courses that are
basically that release all the materials
at once
actually internet connectivity was fine
we struggled a little bit with
electricity the college had great speeds
internet speeds and his everything was
connected through Ethernet but there
were there were few power cuts in my
first year
any other questions yeah go ahead yeah
that's a good question so the question
was how do you basically manage to do
these when you're working and do you do
many at a time or do you focus on one so
I think it's really tough to find time
when you're working I tend to do just
one course right now like while working
because it's really tough to just get
through one course and it's not wouldn't
make too much sense to try to do
multiple and not finish any of those I
think of course is like Udacity courses
that are short shorter or or the ones
that have like frequent checkpoints
where you can evaluate yourself to make
sure you are like getting the concepts
are easier to do right now yeah
I think I may have in the past I think I
tried creating a Python codes for code
Academy I'm not sure I don't remember
how that went and right now it's it
would be legal for me to do work since
I'm on an h-1b visa and for anyone
except my employment
the question was have I created courses
basically yeah go ahead question was
what course am i doing right now I'm
just repeating this for the video so
right now I'm doing the faster di course
it's really tough it's very different
from Coursera and Udacity in that
Coursera and Udacity usually almost hold
your hand through the concepts whereas
faster da he just gives you a bunch of
reading assignments and it's like go
figure it out which is kind of I guess
out the software engineering industry
works too so it says it's a large flow
and after that I hope to do deep
learning da da
so the question was how do I discover
new courses do I go to class central.com
so I usually only go to class central
comm if I want a second opinion
I found that I usually like Udacity
courses and also some EDX courses EDX
courses aren't as standardized so I
can't tell for sure whether I'd be
interested in doing the course so then I
might go to class central.com Coursera
courses I almost never take them because
then they just don't work for me there
exactly and I could call it selection
that it would turn out too great for me
sir
ok I think that's it Thanks
[Applause]